of all the products in the world you
don't want to use market-based
prioritization
it's got to be vaccines
[Music]
there's no technology known to man now
that is faster than money
because of this monopoly or duopoly
position that the sellers are in
they tend to have a high amount of
market power and ability to get higher
prices
vaccines save two to three million lives
every year
but bringing them to market involves
huge investments complex science
and secretive contracts
before the covet 19 pandemic few people
paid attention to the business models
behind vaccines
the global pharmaceutical market was
worth 1.3 trillion dollars in 2019.
vaccines made up just three percent of
that generating around 33 billion
dollars of revenue
that compared to 142 billion dollars
from cancer drugs
so how do the economics of vaccines work
who funds them
how profitable are they and will the
covet 19 pandemic and new technology
disrupt the vaccine market forever
until recently there have really only
been four main players in the vaccine
market
glaxosmithkline merck pfizer and sanofi
they represented 90 percent of vaccine
industry revenues in 2019
even for these market leaders developing
a vaccine is a costly and time-consuming
gamble
the process often takes a decade work on
infectious diseases is often
very obscure because the burden is so
much out of sight
in the rich countries and where the deep
scientific and manufacturing power is
government is the main funder of the
science and that's critical
and you know all of the benefits we have
today if you think about the sequence
analysis or the mrnas and
you know the biotechnology the new
manufacturing all of that came out of
investments in basic science as you go
into phase one trials
these are taken over by industry maybe
one in every ten vaccines in a phase one
trial goes on to be approved
while fifty to seventy percent of
vaccines in phase
three trials end up being approved they
will only
invest once the market and the chances
of success are well known this doesn't
mean there's zero risk
but largely what we see is that the
public sector takes on most of that
but indeed this is what allows the
business of vaccines to operate
the cost of creating a vaccine varies
widely on average it ranges from several
hundred million
to a few billion dollars
supply demand and pricing for vaccines
are determined by a small number of
actors
on the buyer side national governments
and organizations like gavi the vaccine
alliance
and unicef are among the biggest
purchasers
on the seller side are the pharma
companies
because the development costs and
regulatory barriers for vaccines are
high
companies can maintain their monopolies
for longer
it tends to have a high amount of market
power and ability to get higher prices
than
let's say a generic a generic
small molecule drug or even a vaccine
for which we have lots of lots of
competitors
up until gabi was created the global
alliance vaccines in the year 2000
there was no purchasing power to get
those new vaccines
to the kids who needed the most so that
was this great irony that for example
rotavirus
and pneumococcus vaccines uh that now
saved millions of young children's lives
they weren't getting out in these
countries
normally what happens is when vaccines
come out they come out at a high price
in a low volume
and over time as the yield goes up
as other manufacturers begin to produce
it prices come down dramatically to give
an example
are vaccines that are the who approved
vaccines
you know cost over thirteen hundred
dollars if you looked it in the u.s
model and we pay
27 for those so it's a pretty dramatic
difference
gavi typically negotiates procurement on
behalf of 60
of the world's children they try to
ensure low and middle-income countries
pay significantly less for vaccines
than rich countries do if the disease is
in the rich world
one of the western companies will invent
a new vaccine
with huge r d investments they'll charge
a reasonably high price
as much as say a hundred dollars in
western markets
and then eventually either they'll make
a
cogs oriented version
or the indian or other developing
country manufacturers will come in
by prioritizing high volumes at low
prices the serum institute of india has
become the world's largest vaccine
manufacturer by volume it typically
produces more than 1.5 billion doses of
vaccines every year
which are used in 170 countries
this year it has increased capacity and
is aiming to manufacture at least 1
billion doses of cobin 19 vaccines alone
after signing deals with astrazeneca and
novovax
it is more expensive to make a vaccine
in the u.s and europe
traditionally those companies haven't
had large facilities because the
volumes that they sell at are much lower
but at a very high price
[Music]
well these are proprietary products that
the companies have spent
lots of money in high risk in order to
go through trials
they have to recover all of those and
make their profit
from the rich world market and the
middle income market
knowing that those gobby markets are not
not going to give them any
any meaningful margin but returns on
investment are not straightforward
the lack of transparency around each
company's production costs
makes it difficult to assess a vaccine's
profitability
we do know that at the top end pfizer's
pneumococcal vaccine prevnar which works
against pneumonia
generated 5.8 billion dollars in revenue
in 2019.
if you've invested maybe a few hundred
million dollars in the r d
10 15 20 years ago and you have a
captive market
then you're going to make a pretty good
profit a very very healthy profit
somebody would say an excessive profit
at the other end of the spectrum are
well-established low-cost children's
vaccines
like measles low profits drove several
producers out of the market in the 1970s
and 80s
in the past decade an increase in
vaccines for adults and those taken
annually like the flu vaccine
have helped make the market more
profitable but for governments the
health societal and economic returns are
much greater
gavi estimates a 21 return for every
dollar invested in vaccine programs for
the 73 countries it typically supports
well the most salient number is that in
the year 2000
over 10 million children under the age
of 5
died every year by 2016
that number was under 5 million per year
that's
per year that's millions
[Music]
this is the way things were then came
the pandemic
the outbreak of kobit 19 brought china
and then europe to a standstill
as the novel coronavirus spread to the
u.s and across the globe
it wasn't long before governments were
betting billions of dollars on
developing vaccines to fight the
pandemic
a new vaccine market was about to emerge
where demand was unlimited
and governments would do everything in
their power to secure doses
[Music]
the total amounts involved relative to
normal vaccine r d
you know it's tens of billions of
dollars maybe a total of
you know 25 billion or so that's
gigantic in the world of vaccines
now relative to the economic damage of
the pandemic which is in the trillions
it's truly a rounding error this is the
best money that's been spent by
governments during this pandemic
the public sector governments
collectively have really de-risked
and subsidized the r d process every
step of the way
from the early stages of r d oftentimes
to the scale up of manufacturing and of
course purchasing
other big funders include the bill and
melinda gates foundation and sepi
the coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovations is a public-private
partnership that supports vaccine
development to stop
future epidemics one recipient of a
small grant from seppi at the start of
the pandemic was moderna
a biotech company that had yet to bring
a product to market
by the end of 2020 u.s federal funding
for modernist vaccine had swelled into
the billions
and it was approved for use so moderna
took a huge amount of public money
up to four billion dollars from the us
government and that helped them build
this proof of concept
the vaccine uses messenger rna
technology which the company spent a
decade developing
we invested around 3 billion in the last
10 years to get the technology to
displace
the pandemic has accelerated the
companies turning into a commercial
company by
three to maybe four years the first
vaccine approved in a western country
also used mrna
it was made by u.s pharmaceutical giant
pfizer and germany's biontech
while pfizer did not take public funding
to develop and manufacture its vaccine
it did have an initial 1.95 billion
advanced purchase agreement through
operation warp speed
the us government's kobit 19 investment
program has surpassed
10 billion dollars most of which has
been spent on vaccines
it's not the only country that placed
huge bets on vaccines
china and russia funded their own
vaccine candidates
and the german government gave biontech
445 million dollars
the uk government contributed 65.5
million pounds to oxford university
and its vaccine manufacturing partner
astrazeneca received up to 1.2 billion
dollars for trials and manufacturing
from the us government
well there was no point in us generating
a vaccine in january of last year if it
wasn't going to be able to take it all
the way through clinical development and
into emergency use licensure
and as a university we are able to do
much of the early
clinical development and get that taken
quite a long way but we were never going
to be able to manufacture a vaccine
that was going to be used as a licensed
product
the unprecedented public funding helped
these companies develop vaccines in less
than a year
until now the fastest vaccine ever
created was a mumps vaccine developed by
merck in four years
the pandemic demanded an urgent response
but that also led to questions about the
prices of copen 19 vaccines
we have a high degree of secrecy we have
governments really desperate for access
to vaccine supplies and willing to
sometimes pay very very high prices and
things are happening very quickly under
emergency conditions so
it's unfortunately a perfect storm where
the risk of abusive pricing or unfair
pricing
is quite high i think pharma did hold a
lot of power in this negotiation
but i also think that they could have
gone higher plenty of investors actually
would have liked them to gone higher and
didn't make a secret of that
prices for covered 19 vaccines vary
widely
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine is about
three to four dollars a dose
along with johnson and johnson they have
committed to selling their vaccine on a
non-profit basis during the pandemic
astrazeneca say they will do so in
perpetuity for low and middle-income
countries
modernist said it has charged the u.s
government as little as 16
and 50 cents per dose to return some
money to taxpayers
but smaller orders for other customers
range from 32 dollars to
dollars per dose you know we
invested three billion dollar in this
technology since the beginning we've
never made a penny of profit
we thought it was not appropriate not to
make a small profit the value
that we are asking for the product is
way under the value to the healthcare
system
if you just look at the saving in just
hospitalization costs
they run much much higher in habitat
it's very difficult to actually come up
with an evidence-based judgment on the
fairness of any price or the fairness of
any profit merchant
companies want to play countries off
against each other and so aren't very
incentivized
to want to make these contracts
transparent
and democratic governments often don't
want their public to know
that they've gotten a bad deal or they
don't want rival countries to know that
they've gotten a good deal and so
there's not very much incentive for
making these public before the pandemic
u.s pharma companies were under pressure
over high prices for drugs
the industry looked ripe for reform
so then we come into the pandemic and
you have a situation
where some companies say look this shows
how important it is to invest in
innovation
so you should you know pay us a good
amount of money
but then the other hand is some
companies said ah this is our
opportunity to make a contribution by
saying we'll
offer these vaccines on a non-for-profit
basis i think it's reasonable to
allow companies to make a profit from
the high income countries
having put such a huge effort into this
work
and also made sure that it will be
available for lower middle-income
countries
in perpetuity without profit moderna
said it expects to make 18.4 billion
dollars from its kobe 19 vaccine sales
this year
it has not revealed the profit margin
for its covet 19 vaccine
pfizer said it expects to make about 15
billion dollars with a profit margin of
more than 20 percent
the profits will be split 50 50 with buy
on tech
these forecasts have partly shaped the
company's varied share price
performances in the past year
[Music]
in previous pandemics including sars the
outbreak ended before companies could
develop a vaccine
those who invested in the endeavor made
a loss
but covet 19 is widely expected to
become endemic
analysts predict the annual vaccine
market for the virus could reach 10
billion
a year or more as producers tailor
vaccines for new strains
if the vaccines aren't very successful
but they do provide a very meaningful
contribution
to the fight against covid then we're
likely to move to something like a flu
model where
we sell more vaccines for the flu than
we do for every other
vaccinated illness in the world then the
question will be
are there so many competitors in the
market that the price falls
or the price may go up because it will
be more of a
natural normal market where people will
perhaps choose a particular vaccine
because it has a higher efficacy rate
rather than a market where it's
controlled by these gigantic government
contracts
one big question is whether government
should have demanded more in these deals
for subsidizing development and
guaranteeing sales
it does feed into a larger debate that
was already happening
about what happens when governments fund
science especially really basic research
it goes on into the private sector and
it makes the private sector a lot of
money
but not much of that flows back to the
government
for governments of low and middle income
countries the return on investment
calculation is entirely
different they are battling just to
secure supplies of covid19 vaccines
amid a flurry of bilateral deals between
rich countries and vaccine producers
and global disputes about controls over
vaccine supply chains
of all the products in the world you
don't want to use market-based
prioritization
it's got to be vaccines because if you
went that way
you know the rich people in the rich
countries would buy
all the output for quite a while and it
wouldn't be assigned according to who's
at risk
of dying for example getting to the
elderly and the healthcare workers
gavi the world health organization and
sepi set up the kovacs program to
mitigate this and provide equitable
distribution for covet 19 vaccines
the kovacs advanced market commitment or
amc
has raised 6.3 billion dollars and aims
to distribute 2 billion doses this year
with two-thirds of those subsidized for
92 lower-income countries
we also hope that by having global
supply it would reduce
the number of bilaterals and it looked
like that might have helped for a while
but
there really has been a global pen a
panic
given seeing doses being rolled out
people hoarding doses and also
the new variants have made people
nervous the very same governments that
have said yes we
politically support kobach we will put
money into kovacs it will subsidize
other countries
through kovacs they are the very same
governments that have turned around
and said uh we are going to basically
eat up most of the world's existing
volume through advanced purchase
commitments
any head of state is going to think
about i have to protect my people that's
the natural
instinct and that may be true in a
normal situation
but in a global pandemic you're only as
safe
as everyone is safe covid19 has
turbocharged normal market forces
from funding to the speed at which
vaccines were developed
and the subsequent international
scramble to buy them
but are there more fundamental ways the
virus will change the vaccine market
i think the covert 19 pandemic will
completely shake up
the vaccine market and that's because of
these new technologies like messenger
rna
and viral vectors by accelerating them
so fast they've completely shaken up
who's on top who has the potential to
create the next vaccine
the fastest vaccine ever had been four
years you know the ebola vaccine was
around five years
and the fact that this happened in 300
and you know three days
is extraordinary the pandemic was an
opportunity to prove that mrna
or messenger ribonucleic acid technology
could work
the synthetic mrna delivers instructions
to cells in the body to produce the
viral protein
which stimulates an immune response the
success of pfizer biontec
and moderna's mrna vaccines mean the
technology could be applied to a wide
range of other vaccines and drugs
the mrna platform we're going to push
that to the limit
and we should get a lot more vaccines
and you know malaria vaccine or an hiv
vaccine or a tb
vaccine are miraculous things that's
measured in saving millions of lives not
some economic thing
that is about life itself
the speed at which mrna vaccines can be
tweaked to respond to new variants
and then mass-produced could also make
vaccines more profitable
we're going to end up having
technologies like mrna enabling new
vaccines that are going to be you know
best in class and first-in-class that's
going to be able to maintain kind of a
high profitability
i think platform technologies are the
future of vaccine development and
messenger rna is one of them
we haven't really seen messenger rna
vaccines widely used at all before 2020
and in the last year they've gone from
being something of a
niche research area into having massive
impact i believe
we will end up at having the vaccine
that will have
a combination of the seasonal boost for
flu
and the new variant for for sasko v2
there's going to be one shot
so how is that going to compete with a
vaccine not only the seasonal flu
i believe those vaccines will have no
future
there are also reasons to be cautious
about the future of mrna
just because mrna and the viral vector
vaccines have been
pretty successful for covert doesn't
mean they're going to be successful for
everything else and so i think that
there will still be a debate inside some
of these big vaccine players like gsk
sanofi and merck about to what extent
they should
rush towards this new shiny object and
to what extent they should rely on their
own
reliable proprietary platforms you know
i do think for the next pandemic
we will be able to solve the problems of
the
mrna platform that is we'll
fix the thermal stability we'll fix the
scalability
and will fix uh the cost we kind of
caught mrna
halfway to prime time analysts predict
that 2021 vaccine sales from moderna and
novovax
will outpace those from three of the
biggest vaccine producers who dominated
the market before covet 19
merck gsk and sanofi
all three have yet to bring a coven-19
vaccine to market
new players in charge they've got a lot
of capital investors are really backing
them
and they can go into new markets most
obviously flu the big question the
billion dollar question
is you know how many of those firms are
going to find a business model that
allows them to scale up production
and global distribution could the
pandemic propel the vaccine segment into
becoming a much bigger part of the
global pharmaceutical market
vaccines probably save more lives than
any other tool
if we can take vaccines and apply them
more in the area of cancer
then that just changes the numbers
completely because
the cancer market you know is it's
you know over 10 times the r d over 10
times the spend
uh you know potential for growth i do
not think that we're going to see the
entire pharma industry
switch to focusing on vaccines it's
still a business where you often sell to
governments
where they're often very large contracts
and not that much
competition and not that much growth
with more than 113 million cases of
coronavirus confirmed globally
and 2.5 million known deaths vaccines
are widely seen as the key to ending the
pandemic
public investment in vaccines are
dwarfed by the economic costs of this
global health crisis
an estimated six trillion dollars in
economic output was lost in 2020
and another 4.4 trillion dollars will be
lost this year
public health experts have been telling
governments and politicians for years
that vaccine supply is a huge global
strategic priority and that you should
protect it
i think they've finally woken up
traditionally when governments have
tried to invest in that infrastructure
it's not worked out very well
it's always been the private players in
the private sector that's been able to
succeed
scale up because of the entrepreneurship
and freedom that a private sector
company would have
obviously if you want to have
manufacturing facilities ready to go
that are there in case of an outbreak
you're going to need to make sure that
there's financing for that because
from a for-profit company the idea that
you would have
facilities that are available that are
not being optimally used
might not make business sense but they
may make public health sense so i see
this as a
partnership between government and the
private sector
i'm very enthused that vaccines
all the standby capacity that we will
have on
for the next pandemic we may be able to
use that
when there's not a pandemic going on to
create
lots of low-cost supply capacity
for the entire world and you know
imagine that you'd had a vaccine
you know back in the summer you would
have saved millions of lives
coven 19 has already changed the vaccine
market
potentially irreversibly
you